et elisabeth alors est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire des choses ouais je
peux vous dire plein de choses ar alors
d'abord vous êtes une petite balance
petit et si vous le dites si vous le
dites avec un ascendant cancer qui fait
que vous êtes très sensibles à tout ce
qui est familiale la famille
le voilà les origines tout ça c'est
important pour vous je dirais que c'est
pas un hasard si vous m'avez demandé de
faire ça maintenant avec angers fait bon
de monter votre thème que d'ailleurs
voilà qui est là et la voilà je
comprends tous là c'est bon voilà alors
vous voyez tout de suite quand même ceux
qui connaissent un tout petit peu les
les signes là les symboles que vous avez
plein de choses en balance qui est en
bas la sorte de la balance le soleil et
pluton dessus qui donne des gens très
ambitieux mars dessus qui donne une
pêche seulement incroyable seller mars
les baous volonté de puissance non mais
ça c'est l'aspect pour vous c'est pour
quand très bien la part de fortune qui a
quand même comme elle le dit fortune a
la chance voilà si vous êtes quand même
quelqu'un très chanceux alors je me
dirais que vous êtes info comment
dirais-je un fou cynique il est un faux
cynique c'est à dire que vous êtes vous
à vous il ya une part d'idéalisme en
vous que vous que vous avez font tourner
ou ou écrasés se cacher voilà et qui va
ressortir parce que justement et vous
êtes surtout un workaholic je reviens à
cette histoire comme un malade
accro au boulot accro au boulot
cette femme là
vrai ou pas oui non pour l'instant c'est
vrai pour l'instant c'est ouais ouais
alors qu'est ce tu vois toi pas joué
alors tu vois quelque chose voilà j'ai
une fois je voyais aussi à huy alors
justement c'est très important pour
pointer là tu sais pas pourquoi parce
que bon ça ça devient de l'astrologie
hymne à la mystique mais vous avez donc
tout ces facteurs en balance et comme la
balance cette année c'est pas le
meilleur des signes en 2020 en 2000 mais
elle est en danger vous la sublime et
parce que l hérésie par cette vénus que
vous y avez en vierge
voilà qu'est la planète de la balance
justement ah oui et elle se trouve en
vierge et cette vierge reçoit cette
année les vierges ont beaucoup de sens
et à la souris avec les poissons et
rivières les mots si vous êtes vierge
poissons et ont beaucoup de chance cette
année oui on est meilleur signe ouais
les uns des meilleurs signes capricorne
pour 2020 d'alors les poissons d'abord
d'accord les vierges les taureaux
capricorne scorpions et scorpion
scorpions excellent of excellence jean
michel est d'accord pour les capricornes
sait où tout bon ou tout mauvais si j'ai
lu son bouquin ça dépend du thème et ya
rien pour les béliers pour les béliers
et baigné dans les unit à lens vient
avec une vierge ses bons amis dans sa
chance
m
ça je sais que vous adorez ça moi
j'adore ça me passionne donc là je suis
sûr que les téléspectateurs se disent et
moi ce qu'elle va dire mon signe un
récit de les moins bons cette année
c'est quoi donc
le hémois bon ouais bah je dirais les
béliers d'avril suisse a payé 2 mars
ouais mais bon mois d'avril tu voulais
bélier et puis les balances de d'octobre
cas et en plus de mal voilà et les
cancers aussi pour lesquels c'est un
mythe celui de deux choses l'une ou bien
il ya il peut y avoir des problématiques
avec le conjoint ou l'associé à d'accord
d'accord mais enfin c'est quand même une
année un petit pour associer les cancers
alors chanial pas bon oui oui elisabeth
je vais savoir dans le cercle extérieur
il ya que des symboles hilal chiffres 69
à gauche ça veut dire pauvre où ça oui
c'est vrai mais là la voix la soirée
j'accuse les symboles et 69 semaine mais
non c'est le cancer ces cancers cancer
contre la connerie c'est bien vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ou bien les choses
l'astrologie ça veut dire discours sur
les astres en grec logis oui va voir si
je suis dehors ça veut dire d'avoir ce
qu'est ce qui va se passer encore une
fois on fait semblant de pas être
sérieux mais en réalité il est beaucoup
plus sérieux trop sûr c'est vrai la
raison il les avait alors alors vous
êtes un nid de contradictions c'est à
dire rex en itw à la rixe a eu ni de
contradictions vous avez tout fait cet
idéalisme cette voie là et il ya un
moment un moment crucial dans votre vie
c'est pour ça que ça m'a amusé qu'on me
parlait de cette project vous avez et
qui apparaît dans votre thème comme
claire comme l'eau de roche
c'est à dire que à 47 ans donc c'est en
2022 théoriquement voilà voilà
ah oui parce qu'à se passer en fait ce
qu'on voit dans votre thème c'est que le
succès le vrai succès est apparue depuis
la quarantaine est ce que c'est vrai bah
oui bon tardive quoi alors calme toi ta
gueule les autres sept ans il va se
passer quoi exactement parle alors à ce
moment-là c'est un grand tournant dans
sa vie alors de traitement des choses
de toute façon c'est des mauvaises
nouvelles annoncées des noms je rappelle
qu'elle avait annoncé l'élection de
trump bien avant que les vrais
exactement en mars avant qu'il soit même
ouais on est amis merci merci petit
bélier merci parce qu'il est gros mais
comme ça qu'on l'appelle dans le milieu
du sexe
[Applaudissements]
voilà petit mais pas tous les tenues
bonjour à 10,6 d'audience connais depuis
des années j'ai baba donc les connaissez
bien c'est vrai alors on peut pas en
placer une ici mais s'il a fallu alors
on attend ton trou ya 43 ans venant 2022
alors 2021 va être un grand cru pour
vous non si 2021 bien meilleur que
maintenant je demanderai donc ouais
alors c'est un ça va être une espèce de
rampe de lancement pour le projet de
2022 la présidentielle et là on y
revient vous allez déjà changé en 21 des
choses sur le plan médiatique vous allez
changer des choses c'est bien nous
disait parfois ironique ah je suis pas
voyante ya forcément des gens avec l'âge
qui vont nous quitter le tour de la
table ça c'est mécanique un mois on peut
tout faire et contre la nature ont alors
tout à l'heure j'ai abordé l'histoire de
la vénus là en 2020 il ya donc des
soucis familiaux peut-être ou de
domicile mais les décisions début mars
vous devriez prendre des décès à la mare
cela oui ah ouais devriez prendre des
décisions à ce moment là parce qu'elles
seront très porteuse notamment sur le
mois d'août et ça va si vous voulez
juguler ou neutraliser passablement les
problématiques de la balance voilà corps
voilà je dirais que vous devriez vous
associe fait fin février ou qu'on volé
mais qu'on vole sfr convoler où ça où
l'on n'ose aller
non c'est un peu une plaisanterie
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est des blagues de voyants preuve
d'audace trop longue et ont convolé non
[Rires]
il va s'associer encore avec quelqu'un
d'autre
j'en sais rien mais on le sait ces pros
c'est très bon pour les associations fin
février d'accord marié mais comme c'est
fait un mariage heureux mariés ah ben
voilà il faut vous marier en fin février
on va voir le traiteur on est à la
traîne et le nom de notre c'est le vôtre
était marrante
alors vous savez que c'est rigolo vous
avez le milieu du ciel là le milieu du
ciel il est là oh ouais c'est la pointe
de la maison 10 vous voyez que les ya
des numéros à l'intérieur du deuxième le
17 avril voilà et le dise
yao en plein milieu du ciel ouais qui
est à 16 des poissons vous le voyez ça
doit travailler le poisson là ou alors
c'est rigolo parce que c'est exactement
au même endroit
d'abord il reçoit un magnifique afflux
nets depuis l'année dernière de neptune
qui vous pour halluin d'eau arrivent au
porteur non parce que ça c'est vraiment
c'est le grand succès d'accord de plus
depuis l'année dernière les derniers ont
bien avancé c'est marrant parce que
c'est sur le même milieu du ciel que
pascal praud qui a pas mal de succès au
trot et c'est vrai c'est fou c'est fou
avec les dom le même ascendant et le
même arrêt le même milieu du cinéma
bon ça c'est amusant je lis tout de
suite vous ai dit c'est amusant c'est
alors de toute façon vous aurez un
succès médiatique longue durée dans
votre vie ah oui assuré merci qu'ils
avaient alors 2021 je les dis un grand
cru avec une rampe de lancement
d'accord il faut les en 2022 écoutez moi
je pense qu'il ya un grand succès
d'estimé à la clé non oui parce que et
c'est pas fini
je pense que ce sera un tournant dans
votre vie et qu'après vous aurez vous
allez vous adonner à la vie politique
oh la la la la la la la
vous consacrez à la vie politique est ce
que ça vous dit quelque chose non ces
rires non mais oh c'est bon on s'en
servir comme mon émission de radio j'ai
reçu des médiums j'ai posé des questions
concernant votre futur peut-être
réélection en 2022 lycée pas 2022 mais
les cinq ans après donc il se prépare il
va très bien s'en est trouvée ouais
ouais 2025 2027
ah ouais réfléchissez bah écoutes je
vais pas très voyante aussi
[Rires]
non non il y à véritablement 1022
connard il ya une il ya une
configuration qui qui pointe sur 2022
accor est donc je pense que vous feriez
bien effectivement de faire tous les
projets que vous avez bien sûr oui ok
merci vous pouvez faire 2-3 prédictions
tu peux le général pour noter les
missions prévues les visions oui
prévisions exactement voyons exactement
pour nos téléspectateurs qui se trouve
dans le livre en exclusivité ce que vous
pouvez leur dire de 3,2 trois choses
mais ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter du coronavirus ou pas bah
écoutez je pense que je pense que à
partir du 20 février c'est à dire la
semaine prochaine sera gelé m'associer
way où il ya un bel un bel aspect entre
jupiter la chance et c'est la guérison
jupiter aussi et neptune d'ailleurs un
cycle qui concerne ce qui concerne la
france il devrait y avoir un
descrescendo d'accord mais comme cet
aspect se répète en juillet 15 juillet
ça sera peut-être juste le début de
l'heure de la fin voilà je suis pas sûr
que tout de suite du jour où l'on m'a
comme ça ça va il y aura plus de
coronavirus à ce suis pas sûr du tout
j'en sais rien d'accord mais cet aspect
de jupiter neptune qui est un aspect
guérisseurs et du sens et qui est le
cycle de la france juteau rien n'est
figé en est une bien sûr ce allons
enfants de la patrie
exactement j'habitais là tu vois là sont
les mêmes
alors ils se forment trois fois en la
maintenant on février après fin juillet
puis à prêter
et en haut pour la chandeleur en octobre
et donc je pense que néanmoins alors là
c'est un oui c'est un ps ou plutôt c'est
un bémol
d'accord je pense que comme j'ai écrit
d'ailleurs dans le livre page 89 fait
l'analyse de la chine qu'il allait y
avoir une problématique grave en chine
en janvier
c'est ce que vous dites c'est quand même
là que ça a éclaté aux abords la wii est
là il est possible que cette histoire de
coronavirus ce qu on dirait ce soit une
espèce de traînée de poudre qui ne se
terminera quand en octobre à faire ça va
en faire c'est les malades ainsi une
autre question elizabeth est ce que est
ce que emmanuel macron va va être le
prochain président il va se représenter
il va être privé telle ou bien c'est un
nouveau prix parce qu'on va avoir un
nouveau président
comme s'il est écrit dans le livret je
pense que il a de sérieuses chances
d'être encore président ouais d'accord
très bien d'accord ce que vous avez une
autre question pour les arrêter si une
pression qui vous croiserez qui concerne
tout le monde pas la peine de venir s
que fatou va venir à la soirée sadaoui
on en a rien à taper station qui oui
aller est-ce que la situe en france ya
quand même une situation tant rêver
c'est vrai que l'année va être selon
vous est ce que la france va être
apaisées ben non parce que je crois que
déjà au mois de mars là j'ai analysé
seul au mois de mars déjà ça va ça va un
peu c'est nier mais il ya du tumulte ya
de l'agitation mais le pire ce sera en
octobre à leurs mains et sur mois
d'octobre je vais pas le voir là que des
merdes en octobre sans rigoler on va
faire septembre on va revenir en
novembre
elisabeth ce mois d'octobre il en enfer
il est pas bon même sur le plan mondial
il est pas bon du tout moi j'ai à la
balle à la crise de l'hôtellerie
un petit peu d'histoire mais je sens
mieux il pourrait y avoir un conflit
militaire c'est très mauvaise octobre
mais demain départ pour la france j'ai
pas dis là froid pas la france mais un
conflit non pas le mondial là haut et on
n'est pas bon on n'est pas
franco-français la hausse
reste bon ben voilà elisabeth merci
d'avoir été avec nous on est d'accord à
berlin elle est très forte en asie avec
est-ce que c'est non mais c'est derek
accueilli tous et pas c'est pas
n'importe quoi elle travaille beaucoup
là-dessus on va bien sûr la position des
planètes et grandissent avec ses ailes
extrêmement sérieuses et pas on n'a pas
pris mais voilà farid à l'autre genou
contre elle a démarré en 75 ans a
démarré 1,75 a bien sûr pas toi tu vas
finir en 2020
[Applaudissements]